hello everyone and welcome to round six
of the Twenty twenty feet a candidates
tournament it's the leader of the
tournament so far Yanni Pony versus ding
leerin so it's a really incredible game
let's just dive straight into it and
before we do there's a nice photo of the
two of them there you can see and
therefore arriving at the game now with
this thermos bottle and you can see here
he has the nice fancy bit chair whereas
ding prefers the the smaller blue one so
let's just enjoy that for a second and
we're off to what is definitely a great
game so let's check it out nipper with
the white pieces opens with E 4 and we
already seen what thing goes for on e4
in this tournament and their head head
score so far in classical chess is a 1-1
victory each plus 7 rows and with whit
nipple being somewhat better in rapid
chess so that being said II five nine
three Knight to c6 and again Bishop to
b5 the reuleaux pieces on the board
most likely nipper was ready for them to
go for the same line he went against the
Maxine now in that that very nice
gimmick seen one so a sex more fees
defense blush up to a four and the
knight to f6
we have castles by neppo Bishop to e7
and now rook to e1 was played by Maxime
against nipple now also in the
candidates tournament but here in epic
oh sorry against ding but here nipple
goes for d3 transposing into a different
line but one that ding also very often
plays we have b5 Bishop to b3 and d6 now
a3 making room for the - upon a tube we
have castles biding and now Knight to c3
nice day if I'm going after the bishop
as usual but back to a to end now Bishop
to e6 countering white light squared
bishop and before we have special
characters I need to rook captures any
two and now Knight back to c6 and here
we have Bishop to g5 are waiting for the
ax to figure out what to play and here
I'm just going to show you how how Knapp
and therefore reacts in positions like
these so sometimes he likes the stock
here spray from a safe distance as you
can see here there
is thinking about the position and neppo
behind his chair checking what he's
doing
sometimes he gives him the deadly stare
you as you can see here really not
comfortable probably thinking about the
position when someone's staring at you
like that
and sometimes he likes the circle his
prey like this there you can see so now
that we've seen that let's continue the
game
so Bishop g5 and Dean containers with
Queen to d7 it's a movie usually played
here and now of course Knepper wants to
use the d5 square for his night so this
should captures an f6 Bishop captures in
the Knight to d5 now getting the Knights
to to an excellent Square and now a5 and
now this position has been reached
before ding is a player ding plays this
very often it's been shown that night
characters and captures doesn't really
do all that much for white so this
position has been reached by ding twice
in talk to your games he had it once
against mvl and he had it once against
Carson and both of them played c4 here
the game against cost and he lost he was
in the 2017 st. Lewis championship
showdown but against Maxime
when Maxime played c4 it was last year
in London chest classic he drew that
game but here Knepper prepared rook the
b2 and rook the b2 is a new move so it
is as of move 16 that we have a
completely new game and here ding has to
figure out what is this rook to be to
idea doing here as most likely ding-ding
knows all the lines that follow after a
pawn to c4 so look the b2 a new move a
ding decides that he's gonna capture on
before we have 8 captures and now bring
the bishop back to d8 now to simply
control this night a little bit better
now the the night all of the scores are
pretty much covered by the bishop so not
allowing the exchange and now c4 so
what's what's the difference here
yeah dingos knife to d4 he offers a nip
or the chance to double up his pawns in
the center and nipple goes forth we have
Knight captures pawn captures and now
Queen to c2 and the dingos looked ahead
you could kick away the night right away
but you can do that always so being not
in a rush to do anything like that
looked the ei8 first and now
yiiii with ideas of expanding with f4
maybe later in the future be capture
some c4 biding we have Queen captures
and c4 now going after the pawn here but
now c6 pushing back the knight Knight to
f4 and Bishop to g5 now threatening to
bust open White's position here so
knight back to e to with a double attack
on the pawn here and now Dean finds the
excellent d5 so we have it captures on
d5 and now see captures on d5 just
grabbing the pawn back and saying that
okay this is now guarded by our tactic
if you capture here then Bishop to f6 is
just when it wins the game on the spot
so after seek a person d5 we have Queen
back to b3 and now Dean says okay you
your position is a little bit better I
have a double deep on here you have a
very nice pass pawn here but I'm I can
push on the King side and you can so h5
he wants to play h4 and h3 for example
if this pawn gates against h3 there will
be some checkmating ideas here possible
so nipple says I'm not worried about
that
let's just start pushing the passed pawn
so b5 with h4 be 6 by neppo and h3
biding and here first Kings the h1 I
saying that I always want to have the
option of playing Knight g1 to cover the
f3 square so it's gonna be a bit bit say
for now so for example if the Queen to
f5 now you could either go night you won
but you can also go f4 just push the
bishop back Bishop to f6 and now b7r
okay b8 and now Knight to the g1 your
nicely covering all of the squares here
pawn covers this night covers this
you're gonna bring your knight to f3
it's gonna be it's gonna be a good
position for white so after King each
one being decides the first block the
rook with rook F to be 8 so route it to
be 8 and now again you don't want to
play something like characters and
allowed this pin with Bishop to f6 so
instead look F to be 1 by nipple and now
adding more defenders to the to the pawn
here and now I should back the d8
threatening just the capture the pawn
and here instead of b7 attacking for the
rook and rook a 5 it's very hard to see
how white takes advantage of this
because this rook is nicely protected
it's it's hard to see how you would be
able to push away anything from there
and and any capture here will again be
met with a nice pin with the Bishop to
f6 so instead an epic goes for Queen to
b5 saying okay if you trade now with se
captures captures in the Ruby 7 not
allowing you to push then I capture here
I'm gonna capture here I'm gonna play an
IG 1 capture here and slowly but surely
I'm gonna pick off all of your pawns and
have a have a better endgame but this is
actually maybe maybe even the best-case
scenario for ding ding knows that he can
only be worse in the same game and he
already started with 2 losses so he
decides to go for Queen to g4 now
threatening Queen f3 check followed by
Queen to G to checkmate
but feel free to pause the video and
figure out what you would play here for
white it's a very interesting position
well I give you a couple of seconds and
have a nice sip of my water so for those
of you who were able to do it there are
two movies basically which which prevent
Knight g1 also prevents it but it's a
it's a pretty slow idea so it's
basically between Queen captures here
and Queen checks followed by captures
here so both of them keep an eye on the
f3 square which is what you have to do
so for those of you who found Queen to
eh check congratulations that is the
absolute best move but never played
Queen captures on d5 check although we
can't really blame him because to
understand why this is better than just
capturing here I'm gonna show why but
it's it's impossible to figure it out so
point is after this check King gauge 7
Queen captures on f7 now of course you
guard f3 not rook the b7 trying to
deflect the Queen from the from the
defense of the f3 swear now you capture
on d5 again covering this square and now
after well this rook is again under
attack rook a to b8 you're gonna play f3
take away the Queen and after Queen g5
offering a queen trade or something you
just capture on before and now you claim
that you're up three pawns in a
completely winning position and black
doesn't really have any counter play so
this is the point after Queen to e8
check but never played Queen captures
here saying
it's pretty much the same idea if you
don't do anything I still have a target
on f7 so maybe I can use that later and
I'm not leaving this diagonal for
anything but the problem is now the ink
has worked a 5 now just trying to kick
away the Queen and nepo finds Queen to
c6 and it seems like a perfectly good
idea nothing really changes nepos still
has control of the f3 square but here
ding has aligned so impressive so
devious so so impossible to spot and
that line is the reason why that Queen
th check followed by f7 was better than
Queen captures on d5 so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
disgusting line that we speak off well
I'll give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to do it your
your powers of calculation equal those
those of a super engine and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook captures and b6 and here it's just
incredible what happens point is that
after rook captures n b6u play Queen
captures an e2 and now there's really
only one good move here for white that's
a rook to b8 threatening the capture
here but now you have ripped a 5 this is
this is incredible
rook captures here with check King the
h7 and here white is without a good move
because black is threatening Quinta e1
you you will give up the Queen and then
just deliver checkmate now so not for
example if something silly like this
Cherokee deal of the Queen and its mate
because the pawn prevents the King from
reaching the g2 square so what you would
have to do here after King to h7 there
really is is no good move here there if
you go rook to g1 then you allow Queen
captures an f2 and again it's just
better for black for example rookie to
fall by rook captures and h2 will be
made a best-case scenario
so what white can do after king page 7
is only rook the h8 check and go for
this King captures and now Queen to c8
with checking h7 you pick off the h3
pawn with check and now King g6 Bible
and here we have this position where
white is up upon but how are you
defending this pawn so queen f1 you
defended yes but now Queen f3 check came
to g1 and rook to eat you now blocking
the the defense of the d3 point also
there's the there's the threat of route
characters here if if white for example
defense it would rook to d1 but there is
no better way to do it for example if we
do you want you can just capture here
Queen captures captures here with check
and now after Queen f1 we basically
reach an endgame Queen and three points
against Queen and three pawns I didn't
draw so this is this was in the position
and this is the only reason that Queen
to EA to check followed by captures was
better than Queen to be five because
here Dean has this resource
unfortunately for ding he didn't spot it
he played the rook to c5 instead again
tries to get the Queen away from the f3
square but now Napo has Queen ta to
check King to h7 and now not capturing
an f7 but rather Knight the g1 just
keeping an eye on the f3 square like
this and also the pawn keeps an eye on
this square so that King to h1 move
incredibly important that that nipple
found and here
ding decided to go for rook captures and
b6 now perhaps now was a bit too early
maybe maybe keep an eye on the pawn with
Queen to g6 and then try to I try to
ride out the storm but it's very
unlikely after b7 you could go for Queen
captures and d3 now and after Queen
captures here brush up to f6 and now
okay you do have a past D pawn maybe
maybe something can come of this
but ding plate will capture some b6 now
trice the trick nipple again because now
again you have to you have to figure out
what do you do here
if rook captures and b6 now then okay
Bishop captures and you cannot capture
the other bishop because if you do then
rook the c1 with the threat of rook
captures night followed by Queen to d1
which will result in mate so you would
have Quinta efore with check and here we
would basically have another draw Queen
captures D captures and d3 now the route
would have to block it but now rook to
d1 and the problem for white is that
even though he's up
there's no getting the knight or King
into the game for example f4 you can
never get the knight into the game
because the Ruby just spins it and you
can never get the King into the game
because of this point so here we could
even maybe create a passed pawn here
Chris I start pushing it but it doesn't
matter for example e six King f8 Ruby
seven blocking but now G five and the
white the white has no way of improving
the position you cannot move the King
denied nothing if you just do something
like this King yay Trudy seven not much
to do d2 is coming and it's still no way
for for wife to improve g4 for example
came back to f8 and now you can never
even never move the rook away from the D
file because of just rook captures night
and then you promote the Queen so really
tricky idea by Dean but Nippo doesn't go
for route captures here net point still
goes for Queen captures here and now
it's a bit different because now he says
you do your thing after all is said and
done I always have Queen to h4 check and
it is it is true here at being played
rook captures and B do we have rook
captures and v2 and now rook the c1 with
the same threat of characters followed
by mate however Queen to h4 with check
and now Dean has nothing more to do
captures captures we have this endgame
now and rook to d1 so it's a similar
position to the one we just shown where
epic where Dean can pretty much force a
draw because the knight and King can
never enter the game but here Nepos says
I'm just gonna play f3 and here now he
shows that now he's ready to play this
he's ready to pick up this point and
well slowly but surely somehow even
wiggle his way in get rid of this point
but mostly black will not have anything
to do for example if King g6 you're
gonna go Ruby 4 and now if you don't
want to start losing material you have
to play something if you capture here
now the f3 pawn serves as protection
against capturing h3 so now you can
capture on h3 and well not much you can
do here rook captures here King G - now
you can't go back because of Knight f4
check picks up the rope so you'd have to
go back and then after rook captures
this it's just a full piece up it's of
course completely winning for nipple so
ding
I've thought about the position some ten
minutes after after an appropriative
three but then decided not to continue
in the game and then move 40 just as he
reached time control uh I mean without
even reaching time control he has to
make one will move to reach time control
he decided to resign the game so really
a terrible tournament for Dean so far
with three losses but an incredible
tournament for nepo three wins which is
incredible and as he was the leader
after the fifth round he now extends his
lead as he again won a game and he is
that closer to facing Magnus Carlsen in
the 2020 World Chess Championship match
and as Carlsen as Nippo is the only
person amongst the candidates who has a
positive result against caution in
classical games he has I believe four
wins against Carlsen and only one loss
it would be definitely a challenge to
promote so we'll see what happens it's
still young yeah the tournament is still
young we haven't even reached reached
half of it so anything can happen
the neppo had an mo head some
tournaments where he started with +3 and
then he just finished on 50% so I mean
III really do hope he continues but as
you know interests anything can happen
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Sam you know
hands on a Harry Willis a glib chunk of
Randal Ingersoll and the David Dunn for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
feed a candidates tournament thank you
all I will see soon and have an
excellent start of your week